Die Ligatur ist zurück. Wir blicken auf Europas Top-Ligen bei den Männern. Heute schauen wir auf die Premier League mit Uli Hebel, auf die Serie A mit Christian Bernhard, auf die Eredivisie mit Daniel Zander und auf La Liga mit Alex Treuker, jetzt hier im Rasenfunk. Und nun im Programm der Rasenfunk.
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Ja, zweimal Ligatur in einer Woche. Krankheitsbedingt war das der Fall. Ich hoffe, ihr habt schon die Folge zum HSV und zum FCK gehört. Vielen Dank schon mal für das viele positive Feedback, dass da kam. Sebastian Zobel und Nils Bonhoff, ganz tolle Gäste und Eva Lotta, das natürlich super moderiert. Wir wollen jetzt aber sprechen über den europäischen Fußball und dazu begrüße ich mal eine Runde bei mir. Ihr dürft einmal kollektiv Hallo sagen. Hallo. Das hat wie immer ganz fantastisch funktioniert. Aber ich werde nicht aufhören mit dieser Begrüßung. Lasst uns gleich reinspringen. Ich würde sagen, Alex, wenn du magst, dann darfst du mal beginnen. Wir blicken nach Spanien und wir blicken auf Real Madrid, denn die hatten einige Kracher-Spiele jetzt vor der Brust bzw. jetzt hinter sich.
Oh, nämlich.
Von den Statistiken übrigens, da muss ich an Rafinha denken, ich glaub, der hat fast gleiche Statistiken. Ich hab sie jetzt nicht nachgeguckt, aber weil du sie, die grandiosen Statistiken von Salah vorgelesen hat, ich glaub, Rafinha hat sehr, sehr ähnliche Torbeteiligung. Es ist wenn nicht sogar identisch. Ich hab's irgendwo auf Twitter mal aufgeschnappt. Aber ich wollte kurz Pedri loben. Wir hatten ja früher MVP und Anzang Hero. Und ich wollte jetzt keinesfalls Anthony weder als MVP noch als Hero titulieren. Das hätte mir wieder Streb. Deswegen pack ich in beides quasi Pedri rein, weil der Anzang ist und der MVP ist. Für mich der MVP von Barca, für mich der MVP La Ligas, der bestes Mittelfeldspieler in dieser Saison, finde ich in ganz Europa. Und das kommt mir ein bisschen zu kurz, deswegen muss ich hier ein bisschen die Fahne hochhalten, weil sich das in Statistiken nicht niederschlägt. Und das ist das Traurige unserer heutigen Zeit, Max. Alle hauen Statistiken raus, vor allem auf Kurznachrichtendiensten dieser Welt. Und da taugt er halt nicht so auf und dann ja, aber Bellingham schießt immer der 90. immer das Tor und warum ist er nicht der Beste? Ja, schönen Tap-In aus fünf Metern. Okay, das gewinnt ja das Spiel. Aber wie Pedri ein ganzes Spiel von A bis Z beeinflusst. Man schaue sich vielleicht stellvertretend zum Beispiel das Spiel der Sevilla an. Welche Messi-Esken, Xavi-Esken, Iniesta-Esken, wie auch immer Pässe er da spielt über die Kette auf Laminha Mal, der halt, dass ein Torschuss, ein Volley-Schuss halt gehalten wird und dadurch taugt es halt in keiner Statistik auf. Oder es ist halt der vorletzte Pass, wie bei Xavi, bei Iniesta und die tauchen in keinen Statistik auf. Denn wir spielen Fußball, kein Eishockey, da gibt es kein Pre-Assist. Was Petri macht in der Saison ist das Beste, was es in ganz Europa gibt. Und das wollte ich hier mal erwähnen an dieser Stelle, weil das, finde ich, ein bisschen untergeht.
Ja, sehr schön. Und ja, definitiv nicht falsch. Ich meine, jeder, der mal Petri hat spielen sehen, der erfühlt das zumindest so ein bisschen. Du hast so ein Gefühl der Gefahr, wenn du es mit dem gegnerischen Team hältst. Ich mag nur mal an die Europamesserschaft erinnern, da war es so.
Da tauchte er der Welteffentlichkeit so ein bisschen. Menschen, die nicht nur jede Woche Barsche schauen, völlig fairenhaft, taucht er eher auf dem Radar auf, weil da ist man mehr im Fokus, weil er auch autonomal Menschen zuschaut, die eben den Vereinsfußball spezifisch weniger beobachten. Und wir haben quasi wieder den Petri von damals in noch besser. Müsste man Hansi Flick eigentlich mal befragen oder Petri selbst? Zum Einfluss von Hansi Flick würde mich sehr interessieren. Von außen betrachtet, was hat er gemacht? Er hat ihn ein bisschen weiter hintergezogen. Also er spielt quasi in der Doppel-Sechs den offensiveren Part oder den Sechser mit mehr Freiheiten, sodass er quasi Sechser, Achter, Zehner in einem ist und da überall der Maestro auf dem Spielfeld ist und quasi die Fäden zieht, wie man so schön im deutschen Sprachgebrauch sagt und das Spiel beeinflusst mit Tempowechseln. Ballkontakte müsste er im Schnitt 120 pro Spiel haben. Also er ist wirklich der Mastermind des Baser-Spiels. Pressing-resistent wie Busquets zu besten Zeiten, mit einer Übersicht wie Scharvi zu besten Zeiten und mit einer Dribbelstärke wie Iniesta zu besten Zeiten. Also wirklich vereint für mich ohne Witz die drei Spieler in dieser neuen Rolle unter Hansi Flick in diesem angepassten Basersystem und blüht da auf für mich der beste Spieler der Welt aktuell ohne Witz. Ohne Statistik mal die hervorzuheben, weil da werden andere natürlich am Ende in Individual-Awards oben stehen. Salah, Rafinha, zurecht irgendwo.
Aber mit Baserbaes.
Sehe ich nicht so.
Na gut, man kann natürlich auch die These fahren. Also Julian Nagelsmann hat sich eine Hälfte lang vercoacht gegen Spanien. Meiner Meinung nach Pedri war der Grund dafür. Deswegen Can im Mittelfeld, der war auf Pedri abgestellt, damit der keinen Platz bekommt, um seine öffnenden Drehbewegungen zu machen. Gut, wie es funktioniert hat, haben wir gesehen. Im Nachhinein ist natürlich nur der Schiedsrichter schuld. Da sind wir uns eh alle klar. Kann ja nicht sein, dass jemand anders da einen Fehler gemacht hat in dem Spiel. Aber vielleicht war das die Starke von Pedri, die auch dazu geführt hat, wie Nagelsmann da hat spielen lassen. Aber alles weitere, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, könnt ihr in der Folge von Nach dem Spiel damals noch nachholen. Das müssen wir jetzt nicht nochmal aufräumen. Stattdessen blicken wir jetzt endlich auf Daniel. Es tut mir leid, dass ich dich einmal so...
Ja, ich bin ja schuld.
Das Gatta war schon offen, Daniel ist schon raus und dann musste ich nochmal das Lasso rausholen und ihn zurückziehen. Daniel, was hast du uns mitgebracht aus der Eredivisie?
Kein Problem. Ich hab einen wunderbaren Spieler mitgebracht, Ricky van Wolfswinkel. Und Ricky van Wolfswinkel ist schon 36, also auch schon in einem gediegelten Festspieleralter. Aber er hat einen wirklich immensen Wert für Twente Entrelde. Er ist in der Saison eigentlich so ein typischer Backup-Stürmer. Der ist Kapitän, also hat auch in der Mannschaft so verschiedene wichtigen Punkte, wichtige Golde, die er einnimmt, ist dann mehr so der Kabinenspieler, der es war auch im Hintergrund der Mannschaftsgefüge gut harmoniert und er so für die letzten 20, 30 Minuten in Pulse bringt. Nun ist es aber so, dass sich Ende Dezember Sem Lamas, das ist eigentlich der Nummer-1-Stürmer von Twente, verletzt hat. Und sie sind, Twente ist rar gesät, was Sturzstürmer angeht. Sie haben dann noch ein 18-jähriges Talent. Den Namen kennt man vielleicht, das ist Lukas Wennehorf Hesselink. Das ist der Sohn von Jan Wennehorf Hesselink, der, herausragend Name, wie ich finde, spielt bei Twente, 18-jähriges Talent.
Van Wolstwinkel ist aber auch nicht so schlecht, muss man sagen.
Genau. Van Wolstwinkel ist auch nicht so schlecht.
Sendet sei damit auch schon überzogen, mit beiden Namen.
Also und dann ist es so gewesen, dass sich Lammers verletzt hat, das heißt, Van Wolstwinkel musste ran, den gesamten Januar und jetzt auch bis Februar und hat das einfach wirklich gut gemacht. Also er hat die zwei Tore jetzt erzählt in den Spielen, ich glaube vier, fünf Spiele waren es, ist aber auch einfach wichtig als Wandspieler, der einfach auch die Bälle festmacht und verteilt und steht so ein bisschen im Schatten von A. Sam Lammers und aber auch B. Franz Sam Stein, der schon 17 Tore gemacht hat, Sam 20 spielen und bei Twente eigentlich so der, das wäre quasi der MVP bei Twente. Und in dem Schatten befindet sich Van Walswinkel, aber ich würde einfach nur mal ihn Lob reisen, dass er eben auch ein wichtiger Bestandteil von Twente ist und vor allem jetzt bei dem Ausfall von Sam Lammers diese Rolle als Startelfstürmer herausragend ausgefüllt hat und es immer noch drauf hat. Und spannend wird jetzt zu sehen, was passiert, wenn Sam Lammers wieder fit ist. Also ich denke nicht, dass Lammers dann lange auf der Bank sein wird. Ich denke, dass Van Walswinkel dann auch ohne zu lamentieren, dann wieder auf die Bank gehen wird. Aber mal gucken, er hätte sich auf jeden Fall mehr Spielzeit verdient, würde ich sagen. Und das ist eine kleine Geschichte. Und dann wollte ich jetzt auch noch eine andere Geschichte erzählen, weil das ist ja wieder unfassbar eigentlich. Denn vor zwei Wochen war es so, dass in dem Spiel Herrn Fehn gegen Fortuna Sittard gab es dann doch einen Fall für die Schiedsrichter und einen Fall für den Liga-Verband. Es war in der 88. Minute beim Standverband 2 zu 1 für Herrn Fehn der Fall, dass Sittard doppelt wechseln wollte. Und es kamen auch zwei Spiele aufs Feld, aber nur einer ging runter. Das heißt, die waren tatsächlich für fast eine halbe Minute mit zwölf Mann unterwegs. Und genau in dieser Spielphase, wo Sittard mit zwölf Mann unterwegs war, gab es einen Einwurf, der ausgeholt wurde, mit diesen zwölf Spielern. Und erst dann ist es nochmal aufgefallen, der Spieler ging runter und dann wurde es mit 11 gegen 11 vorgesetzt. Aber natürlich, aus dem Einwurf gab es eine Ecke. Und aus der Ecke resultierte das 2-2, der auch das Endstand war. Und dann gab es natürlich einen großen Aufschrei. Und jetzt, die vorgestern, hat der Verband entschieden, ja es bleibt alles so wie es ist. Das 2-2 hat Bestand. Und als Grund wird angeführt, dass dieser Einwurf ab damit 11 gespielt wurde und dass der Fehler einen nicht-sektifikanten Einfluss haben soll auf das Endergebnis. Das heißt, ist so ein bisschen die Kategorie Glücksfilz der Woche. Das hat sich das 2-2 noch bestand. Bei Sitzart, ja.
Das ist so unglaublich. Ich weiß noch, ich hab das mitbekommen, weil im Rasenfunk Discord, in Offiziellen, da hat das jemand gepostet mit hier, sag mir mal, welche Formation das ist. Und da dachte ich mir, das ist so typisch Rasenfunk, dass die jetzt hier die Formation von Fortuna Sitzart aufdröseln, weil die wahrscheinlich irgendwas ganz Tolles machen. Und dann hab ich gezählt und hab gesehen, ah, das ist das berühmte Chelsea 443, das wir schon seit einer ganzen Weile nicht mehr gesehen haben. Und ja, aber es ist ja irre, dass das dann trotzdem zählt. Obwohl es ja so ein eindeutiger, na gut. Aber ja, sehr schön, haben wir das hier auch noch abgedeckt. Das ist ja fast schon wieder untergegangen. Dann hatten wir jetzt zwei Geschichten aus der Ehre die Wiese. Weißt du was, Christian? Dann hau jetzt auch zwei Geschichten raus. Heute ist einfach die wilde Ligatur.
Wow. Ja, jetzt bis auf die Schiedsrichtergeschichte gerade von Daniel, habt ihr ja so viele schöne Geschichten gehabt, so viel Positives. Dann crash ich das jetzt mal mit ein bisschen was ziemlich Enttäuschenden und komm mit Monza ums Eck und zwar dem Niedergang von Monza. Vielleicht erinnerst du dich noch ein paar vor relativ kurzer Zeit. Monza erstmaligst in der Clubgeschichte aufgestiegen. Berlusconi als Eigentümer, Gagliani als Manager. Und dann war ja schon so ein bisschen die Frage, weil die da auch sehr viel investiert haben. Ja, war klar. Eigentlich war die Idee, dass die dann relativ schnell auch auf die linke Tabellenhälfte rüberwandern quasi, also das Ganze eher nach oben interpretieren. Ja, jetzt schauen wir uns die aktuelle Tabelle an. Monza ist mit Abstand letzter, hat von 24 Saisonspielen zwei gewonnen, hat 13 Punkte geholt aus 24 Spielen. Ist im Prinzip, kann man sagen, nach der Hinrunde fast schon abgestiegen. Sie haben acht Punkte Rückstand auf den ersten Nicht-Abstiegsplatz. Und wie gesagt, mit 13 Punkten aus 24 Spielen kann man sich ja mal ausrechnen, was da acht Punkte bedeuten. Und deswegen ist schon mal spannend, kurz mal drauf auf, drauf zu schauen, was da passiert ist eigentlich. Und da müssen wir anfangen mit, ja, das Silvio Berlusconi ist ja gestorben mittlerweile und seit er eben nicht mehr da ist, ja, ist da halt vieles weggebrochen. Seine Söhne, seine Töchter haben relativ schnell klargemacht, dass das finanzielle Engagement, das der Vater noch geleistet hat, eben nicht mehr fortgesetzt wird. Und ja, und jetzt haben wir die Situation, dass schon im vergangenen Sommer haben sie die Gregorio an Juve abgegeben, Torhüter Colpani an die Fiorentina, Carlos Augusto, der mittlerweile eine wichtige Rolle bei Inter spielt. Also man sieht, da waren viele Spieler da, mit denen ja eigentlich hätte weiter der Weg beschritten werden sollen. Die sind jetzt alle abgegeben worden. Mit Palladino, einer der spannendsten Trainer, mittlerweile bei der Fiorentina, haben wir ja auch schon darüber gesprochen, hast du den Erfolgstrainer im Sommer verloren. Und jetzt ist es so und deswegen fand ich passt das jetzt so wunderbar. Jetzt haben eigentlich, siehst du die Resignation, die sie eigentlich schon da haben, siehst du auch in den letzten Transfer-Tagen im Januar, jetzt haben sie nur mal mehr oder weniger das letzte Tafelsilber, das sie haben, haben sie auf den Transfermarkt auch gebracht. Sie haben Maldini, ein Atalanta abgegeben, das war sicherlich der spannendste Spieler, der Sohn von Paolo Maldini. Sie haben Bondo eben, den laufstarken Mittelfeldspieler, an Milan abgegeben. Sie haben Juric, den Neuner abgegeben. Und im Prinzip also ist es ein Eingeständnis, dass die eigentlich wissen, dass jetzt alles schon Richtung Serie B geht. Also die probieren sozusagen im laufenden Betrieb, sich aufzustellen für die nächste Saison. Dazu passt das jetzt mit Nesta. Alessandro Nesta hat auch den Trainer zurückgeholt, den sie vor eineinhalb Monaten gefeuert haben, weil Boquete, der Nachfolger von zwölf Spielen, elf verloren hat. Und jetzt holst du dir Nesta halt eben wieder zurück, was auch meiner Meinung nach dahin schon deutet auf nächstes Jahr, weil Nesta eben die letzten Jahre in der Serie B getrainiert hat, viel Erfahrung da hat. Und das sind eben alles so Zeichen, dass eigentlich bei innen Monza, bei Gagliani klar ist sozusagen. Das Kapitel Serie A ist jetzt erstmal vorbei und jetzt probieren sie sich so ein bisschen zu erneuern. Schon im laufenden Betrieb haben jetzt zum Beispiel im Winter mit Zerolli ein großes Talent von Milan ausgeliehen. Gagliani lässt ja logischerweise seine Connections spielen. An Camarda waren sie auch dran von Milan, denn das große Sturmtalent, das haben sie am Ende nicht bekommen. Aber es geht jetzt einfach darum, da im Sommer in der Serie B wieder anzugreifen. Aber schon krass eben, wie schnell dann halt auch so ein Abstieg passieren kann. Ein Satz noch dazu war jetzt nicht nur Verkäufe, sondern auch Matteo Pesina. Das war so ein bisschen das Gesicht dieses neuen Monsters, den haben sie ja von Atalanta geholt als Nationalspieler. Also es war quasi ein Zeichen der Stärke zu sagen, schaut mal her Monster, wir sind jetzt da, wir wollen da auch mitmischen. Gebürtiger Mann aus Monster, also der sollte auch das Gesicht werden und der fehlt jetzt zum Beispiel in dieser Spielzeit wahnsinnig viel verletzt. Das tut ihnen halt einfach weh, weil sie eben viel andere Qualität verloren haben. Ja und jetzt geht's eigentlich straighten Weges Richtung CRB. Mal schauen, was dann nächsten Sommer passiert.
Und wenn wir bei Transfers sind, dann können wir auch noch über dein zweites Thema sprechen, was du noch mitgebracht hast. Denn wer auch nur irgendwie mitverfolgt hat, was Como so gemacht hat, bei dem ist das Wort Transfer hängen geblieben.
Ja, Uli kann schon zurecht grinsen. Da ist es einfach wahnsinnig spannend bei Como. Kurz zur Einordnung, Como wird ja von Fabregas trainiert, ist auch aufgestiegen, aber ist halt alles andere als ein normaler Aufsteiger, weil die wahnsinnig viel finanzielle Power in der Hinterhand haben. Das sind die Eigentümer, das sind die Gebrüder Hartono, das ist eine indonesische Brüderfamilie. Die sind mehrere Milliarden Dollar schwer. Also die spielen wirklich im ganz, ganz großen Game mit, was die finanziellen Möglichkeiten betrifft. Ja, und kommen wir jetzt einfach mal zwischen Sommer-Transferfenster plus jetzt Winter-Transferfenster geschmeidige 100 Millionen ausgegeben für einen Aufsteiger. Dazu muss man sagen, auch jeweils 50-50. Also die haben jetzt auch im Winter einfach nochmal 50 Millionen nachgelegt. Und das Spannende ist, da ist viel Aktionismus, klar. Aber das sind auch sehr viele interessante, spannende Leute, weil sie junge Leute kaufen, weil Fabregast da ein Riesenanker einfach ist, ein Magnet, der da Connections gerade nach Spanien hat, talentierte Leute halt. Der hat jetzt zum Beispiel von Betis Assane Diou geholt, den kennt Alex sicher, haben sie einfach mal 14 Millionen hingelegt. Carre, haben sie aus Lyon geholt für 15 Millionen. Duvikas von Celta für 14 Millionen Stürmer. Also da kommen viele spannende Leute, entwicklungsfähige Leute. Es hieß sogar, dass es im Winter ein Angebot an Theo Hernandez gab. Also nur mal zu verdeutlichen, in welchen Sphären da Cormo halt auch quasi vorzudringen gilt. Denn das, was für Monster gilt, diese Möglichkeiten weit nach oben zu kommen, die ist bei Cormo definitiv auch da. Also der Plan ist ganz klar, sozusagen da die nächsten Jahre auch, ja wie soll man sagen, andere fußballerische Sphären anzugreifen. Und dementsprechend ist es wahnsinnig spannend. Das ist wahnsinnig spannend, weil Fabregas genau den Fußball spielen lässt, glaube ich, den man mit dem Spieler Fabregas verknöpfen würde. Ich meine, über Fabregas muss man auch nicht viel sagen, was der für ein Spieler war. Und genauso möchte er Fußball spielen, das ist ein sehr dominanter Ansatz, Ballbesitzansatz, riskanter Ansatz, der dazu führt, dass Cormo eigentlich gerade gegen die Guten immer richtig gut aussieht, weil die einfachen, feinen Ballspielen haben zum Beispiel, was Abschlüsse betrifft, sind die Statistik in der Liga, glaube ich, Platz vier. Also die haben mehr Abschlüsse als Napoli, mehr Abschlüsse als Milan, mehr Abschlüsse als Juve. Also das ist eine Mannschaft, die über Sport, die über Ballbesitz und Dominanz kommt, aber sie steckt halt trotzdem mittendrin im Abstiegskampf, haben jetzt gegen Milan, Inter und Juve immer gut ausgeschaut, aber knapp verloren. Und dementsprechend gilt es da jetzt, die Balance zu finden, aus mit talentierten Jungs diesen Fabregas-Fußball zu spielen, aber halt trotzdem jetzt erstmal die Klasse zu halten, denn darum geht's. Und dann bin ich mir sicher, dass die nächsten Sommer wahrscheinlich noch mal anders angreifen werden auf dem Transfermarkt. Also sehr spannendes Projekt. Ich glaube auch, dass sie drin bleiben, weil es einfach viel zu viel... Ja, das glaube ich ist erster Anfang bei denen, weil die, wie gesagt, Fabregas, das sind ja auch Ori und Dennis Weiss, sind ja auch Miteigentümer. Also die haben schon, die haben schon noch viel größere Pläne und dementsprechend sehr, sehr spannendes Projekt.
Eric Garcia von FC Barcelona wollten sie ja auch im Winter holen und da gab es offenbar auch schon eine Übereinkunft und dann hat Hansi Flix ein Veto eingereicht.
Also diese...
Sie haben auch viel günstiges Geld, ich glaube sieben bis zehn Millionen oder so bekommen.
Ja, also gerade diese Verbindungen, die Fabregas nach Spanien hat, die sind halt Gold wert. Also der erholt sich da wirklich Leute so ein Diao und so. Also da waren auch ganz andere dran, aber da zieht halt Fabregas dann auch und das ist schon, das ist schon sehr spannend. Also wie gesagt, ich gehe fest davon aus, dass wenn die drin bleiben und ich glaube, die bleiben drin, weil die einfach viel zu viel Qualität haben im Vergleich zu der restlichen Konkurrenz da hinten drin, dann holen die glaube ich im Sommer noch mal anders aus.
Ihr Stadion werden sie auch modernisieren in den nächsten Jahren hab ich gesehen. So gab es ein neues Stadionmodell. Also die haben einiges vor auf meinem Koma.
Aber Christian, du hast ja vor ein paar mal gesagt, Fußball ist nicht Manager spielen oder Konsolen spielen. In dem Fall schon ein bisschen. Ja, absolut. Ein kleines bisschen.
Du hast völlig recht. Absolut. Also es ist, man kann es auch als aktionistisch betiteln. Definitiv. Ich will es auch nicht zu positiv frameen, weil es ist, hallo, nochmal klar, 100 Millionen für einen Aufsteiger und was da alles kommt. Ich sage nur, was spannend ist, dass halt viel Junges kommt und viel Entwicklungsfähiges. Also die holen jetzt nicht. Es war ja damals diese Dingnummer im Sommer, die überhaupt nicht funktioniert hat. Ah, mit Varan. Das war so eine Nummer, würde ich sagen, oh mein Gott. Wenn ihr mehr von den Nummern macht, dann fährt ihr das Ding an die Wand. Aber die Leute, die sie halt mittlerweile holen, die haben schon großes Potenzial. Aber ja, es ist, gebe ich dir völlig recht, es ist logisch ein bisschen.
Ich glaube immer noch, das haben wir auch schon mal ganz kurz bei RONDO TV besprochen, Tony Blum hat da ja auch seine Finger drin, der bei Brighton ja der Besitzer und auch Datenmann ist. Ich weiß das nicht, das ist nur eine Vermutung, ich versuch das rauszufinden irgendwann mal. Ich hab immer noch das Gefühl, die probieren da irgendwelche Zusammensetzungen von irgendwelchen Algorithmen aus. Wie kriegst du sonst KEMF und VARAN zusammen in einer Transferperiode?
Das ist ja sowieso der größte Fehler, den ich gemacht habe, hier als Moderator, dass ich nicht den alten Sportjournalisten diese Unsitte zu machen, dass ich nicht gesagt hab, was ist bei Marc-Oliver KEMF und Yannick Engelhardt's KOMO los? So hätte ich es natürlich anmoderieren müssen. Völlig liegen gelassen.
Dieser Deutsche spielt unter einer Legende.
Genau. Das ist dann die Weite.
Das klingt aber nach Online-Journalismus dann. Das ist eine Clickbait-Überschrift bei Anschlägen, Portalen, dann Ulli.
Wie soll ich dir jetzt sagen, wo Podcasts veröffentlicht werden? Das machen wir nach der Sendung. Wir machen noch eine Quick-Runde bzw. Ulli darf jetzt noch schnell sein zweites Thema und leg gleich dein drittes hinterher und dann gehen wir jetzt noch schnell durch.
Streng genommen hab ich ja eh schon zwei gebracht.
Da siehst du sehr gut.
Aber wie ihr wollt, ich hab noch oder hätte noch mitgebracht, einfach nur noch mal in einem alten Moment zu denken, umfasst aber auch ganz gut, dass bei Everton sich was rührt. Die haben David Moyes zurückverpflichtet. Das kann man jetzt entweder als Feel-good-Story nehmen oder aber einfach nur, wenn man eingefroren wäre, zwölf Jahre lang hätte nichts mitbekommen, dann wärs auch so wie es immer war. Aber nichtsdestotrotz, die spielen wieder gut, die schießen plötzlich Tore, die haben gestern dann gegen Liverpool sogar noch hinten raus, 90 plus 8 glaube ich war es dann am Ende ausgeglichen, 2 zu 2. Das letzte Mercy Side Derby im Goodison Park, den ich sehr, sehr, sehr vermissen werde, muss ich sagen, zeigt zum einen, dass die Meisterschaft theoretisch noch mal spannend werden könnte. Also ich glaube das zwar nicht, aber es sind in Anfangsreihen nur noch plus 7. Jetzt haben wir ja gleich auf, was die gespielten Spiele betrifft bei Liverpool. Arsenal wird aber wahrscheinlich ohne Harvards diese Saison zu Ende spielen müssen. Das heißt, könnte sich rechnen, dass die nichts gemacht haben im Winter. Die hätten ja nur dann was gemacht, wenn sie total überzeugt gewesen wären. Bei Everton bin ich mir inzwischen sicher, dass die die Klasse halten werden. Mal wieder. Es geht einfach, sie versuchen alles, aber sie steigen einfach nie ab. Und wenn man irgendwie noch mal Zeit hat, kriegt man glaube ich in sozialen Netzwerken ganz gut abgegriffen. Dann schaue man sich nochmal die letzten Szenen dieses Derbys an, weil ein sogenanntes Friendly Derby war es dann nicht mehr. Einige Platzverweise und dieses 90 plus 8. Umfassend für, ich hätte in der Periode vom letzten Rasenfunk Liga Tour, Aufnahmezeitpunkt bis hin zu dem 580 Themen mitbringen können, weil es so viel passiert ist, nicht immer so. Aber in dem Fall ist es wirklich so, diese Liga lebt gerade wieder. All die Klischees super aus.
Sollte man vielleicht Click and Rush hören, aber das wissen ja die Hörerinnen und Hörer sowieso schon, dass das der Weg ist, noch umfassender informiert zu werden. Wir haben noch ein ganz klitzekleines Thema aus der Liga. Alex, du hast gesagt, du kriegst das kurz hin. Ich bin gespannt.
Ich gebe mir Mühe es kurz zu machen. Ja, weil wir besprechen ja hier immer auch über das, was so die Liga beschäftigt und die Themen, die man vielleicht nur am Rande mitbekommt oder teilweise gar nicht mitbekommt. Und dass wir die dann besprechen. Deswegen ist es tatsächlich notwendig, sage ich mal, über die Schiedsrichter-Affäre zu sprechen oder den Schiedsrichter-Streit quasi in La Liga, weil wir es vorhin ganz kurz thematisiert hatten. Real Madrid hat bei Espanyol 1 zu 0 verloren und hat unglücklich verloren. Und sie geben dem Schiedsrichter die Schuld, denn Romero, das war der Torschütze in der, ich glaube 86. zum 1 zu 0, der hätte nicht mehr auf dem Platz stehen dürfen, weil Kilian Wappé von hinten wirklich brutal umgesenzt hat. Und der Schiedsrichter gab keine rote Karte, der war blieb still, was wahrscheinlich der größere Skandal ist oder die größere Fehlentscheidung, dass der war und nicht sagt, guck dir das an, das ist eigentlich rot. Und ja, und weil eben Justas der Torschütze war und er hätte wirklich rot sehen müssen, da gibt es keine zwei Meinungen. Hat Real Madrid infolgedessen einen Schiedsrichter-Brandbrief quasi an verschiedene Institutionen geschickt, hat sich also heftig über das Schiedsrichterwesen in La Liga beschwert und das war ziemlich, ziemlich heftig. Also da stand ich, ich hab sie jetzt mal vor mir, ich zitiere nur, in diesem Brandbrief und in diesem Beschwerdebrief war von Wettbewerbsverzerrung, Betrug, Manipulation, die Rede und dieses Spiel bei Espanol, also diese Fehlentscheidung, diese nicht rote Karte sei der Höhepunkt eines komplett heruntergekommenen Schiedsrichtersystems gewesen. Ein System, das, Zitat, systematisch korrupt sei und darauf bedacht, sich selbst zu schützen. Also ein Rundumschlag von Real Madrid, ein öffentlich gemachte in einem öffentlichen Schreiben. Und ja, ist natürlich dann ein ziemlich großes Thema und darauf hat La Liga jetzt reagiert logischerweise und vor der Disziplinar-Kommission des Verbandes RFEF Anzeige erstattet. Also da geht es dann in irgendwelche legalen Geschichten rein, dass man da quasi jetzt auf institutioneller Ebene, weiß ich nicht, vielleicht irgendwelche Beschwerden...
Ausgerechnet Real Madrid.
Ich wollte es nicht so sagen, Nils, aber Nils sag ich schon. Nils hätte aufgepasst, ausgerechnet Real Madrid. Der muss mich immer verkneifen, so was zu sagen.
Ich mein, Basa hat da ja auch seine Vorgeschichte, aber bei Real hatten wir ja im Oktober diese wunderbare Geschichte, dass ein Ex-Schiedsrichter zugeschaltet ist in einer TV-Sendung und dessen Papagei fängt auf einmal im Hintergrund an, die Hymne von Real Madrid zu pfeifen.
Ja, also es ist ein Riesenthema, ich wollte es kurz machen, ich galoppiere ein bisschen durch. Sie haben jetzt natürlich auch einen Elfmeter gegen sich bekommen, gegen Atletico und dann ist natürlich der Aufschrei enorm, weil jetzt darf ja nichts mehr Elfmeter sein. Der war auch ein bisschen zwielichtig, also ich hätte ihn nicht gegeben, sag ich auch ehrlich, aber er ist jetzt nicht komplett falsch. Auf jeden Fall fühlen sie sich natürlich etwas bedrogen jetzt. Und das ist dann ein bisschen unglücklich, wenn das ausgerechnet Real Madrid ist, denn die Statistik in La Liga ist, das war der erste Elfmeter in der ganzen Saison gegen Real Madrid und sie haben 20 glaube ich für sich bekommen, also ein Plus Minus von 19 und die nächste Mannschaft ist Barca mit Plus Minus 7 oder irgendwie sowas. Also es passt nicht ganz in den Zeitgeist, dass sie sich so benachteiligt fühlen, aber sie sprechen natürlich was nicht zwingend Falsches an, denn die Schiedsrichter sind sehr, sehr schwach in La Liga. Nur, und das ist jetzt das Thema, machen die das absichtlich? Also ist das wirklich Manipulation und systematische Korruption oder sind die einfach nur bodenlos schwach? Ich würde zur Letzteren zendieren, man kennt es ja in der Bundesliga auch, das sind viele Entscheidungen, die kann man nicht verstehen oder die kann man so oder so auslegen und sie werden aber in jedem Spieltag anders entschieden. Also mal gibt's für von hinten in die Beine rot durch den wahr, weil der Schier ist nicht sieht und mal gibt es das nicht eine Woche später und mal schaltet sich der wahr nicht ein und mal schaltet er sich ein und das ist wirklich ein Thema, da hat er einmal in der Sache wahrscheinlich recht oder in der Beschwerdesache, dass die Schiedsrichterei nicht gut ist. Also auch in den letzten drei Wochen, vier Wochen gab es Entscheidungen, rote Karten hier und keine rote Karte da. Man kann das nicht verstehen. Es ist wirklich, du würfelst quasi die Entscheidung und das ist schwierig, aber quasi so ein Brief so zu formulieren ist eine andere Qualität. Und die Eskalationsstufe ist schon bemerkenswert hoch.
Du hast es viel diplomatischer formuliert.
Genau. Und das ist ja, also direkt gewürfelt wird ja vielleicht nicht. Und aber alle, die sich über DFB-Schiedsrichter beschweren, ich möchte nicht sagen, dass das komplett aus der Luft gegriffen sei, sich manchmal zu beschweren. Aber die können ja dir zum Beispiel mal bei Blue Sky folgen. Da bekommt man nämlich was aus Spanien mit. Vielleicht kann man noch mal ein bisschen gucken, was in England so los ist bei manchen Schiedsrichterentscheidungen und nicht wie AA. Eingriffen und so weiter und irgendwelche Koks, einen Schiedsrichter, die ihren Jürgen Klopp hasst, dann im Nachhinein rauslassen. Also vielleicht ist es dann doch alles nicht ganz so schlimm in Deutschland, wie man immer tut.
Also ich halte es für schier ist auch für ziemlich unfähig. Muss man leider so knallhaar sein.
Das ist gar nicht so rausgekommen, Alex.
Die Entscheidung, also wir sprechen bei Tiki Taka im Podcast ja jede Woche drüber und das sind wirklich jetzt hat Fermin Lopez rot gesehen und wurde den Ball wegspitzelt und das ist jeder, der Fußballspiel weiß, das ist keine rote. Aber in der Superzeit, wo du siehst halt kurz das Frame wurde im Follow-Through, der der Fuß so weit oben ist und das sieht halt verzernt aus. Aber und dem Schiedsrichter wurde quasi die vorherige Einstellung gar nicht gezeigt, dass er sieht, dass das eigentlich eine Fußballaktion ist, sondern ihm wird nur das gezeigt, wo der Ball, wo der Fuß da oben ist. Offene Sohle, ja zeigt doch die drei Sekunden vorher, wird ihm nicht gezeigt. Aber dann entscheidet er auf Rot. Aber eine Woche vorher wird ein Papier umgehauen oder zwei und das ist knallrot. Und da geht er nicht mal an den Schiedsrichter, an den Bildschirm der Schiedsrichter. Ja genau, vom VAR. Und das sind so Sachen, wo du dir denkst, jede Woche was anderes und jede Woche wird eine ähnliche Entscheidung komplett anders ausgelegt und mal zeigt er direkt Rot, mal schaltet sich der VAR ein, obwohl er es nicht sollte. Mal schaltet er sich gar nicht ein und du denkst, warum zeigt der ihm das jetzt nicht? Das ist schon, das ist nicht gut, Max, das ist nicht gut.
Ja, ist mir zu generell, aber weißt du, wie oft bin ich auf der Couch bei Günther ja auch schon Millionär geworden. Da krieg ich es auch hin. Die müssen es halt in Sekunden schnell...
Ich hab schon Spiele gepfiffen, Uli, ne?
Ja, ich hab schon Spiele gepfiffen, aber aller Liebe und bei allem...
Ich darf mir das erlauben, wollte ich damit sagen.
Wenn ich nicht die Knieverletzung gehabt hätte, würde ich jetzt auch in La Liga spielen, das wissen wir alle.
Aber allem Respekt, B-Klasse ist nicht...
Ich hab jeden Respekt vor dem Schiedsrichter, aber im Zeitalter von war, musst du den Romero vom Platz stellen, wenn er einen BP von hinten umhaut, weil er ihn nur umhauen will. Und das kann nicht sein, dass ein wahr da stumm bleibt.
Die Frage ist ja aber, wenn Fehler passieren, wie wird damit umgegangen und wenn dann im Nachhinein gesagt wird, ja, das war ein Fehler, dann ist es schon mal viel, viel besser und dann muss man an den Worten dann gemessen werden.
So transparent wird damit nicht umgegangen in Spanien.
Das ist natürlich dann genau ein Team.
Real Madrid hat zum Beispiel die offizielle VAR-Kommunikation angefordert. Die wollten wissen, was hat er besprochen mit dem Schiri. Es wurde ihn verwehrt vom Liga-Verband. Ich glaube auch deswegen haben sie quasi die Worte Manipulation, Bedrug und Verzerrung und Korruption. Oder sich selbst zu schützen. Sind jetzt die Zitate in diesem Brandbrief gewählt, weil eben, ja, weil das so ein System ist, wo man sich selbst schützt. Und ich glaube, das kann man aus der Bundesliga dann schon auch ein bisschen. Gibt es Parallelen, Max? Ich weiß es nicht. Vielleicht Schiedsrichterwesen als.
Ja, also Stichwort selbst schützen. Da schütze ich uns jetzt mal selbst und sage, ich finde ich gut. Und wir machen das mal anders. Daniel, was hast du denn noch aus der Ehredivise? Ich hoffe, es sind keine Schiedsrichter-Themen. Bitte, bitte, bitte.
Nee, das hat nichts, sondern einfach noch mal schön zum Abschluss ein MVP und zwar von Diventa. Das schließt so ein bisschen nach und an, dass ich ja gesagt hab auch schon vorhin, dass Oliver Edvardsen jetzt vor einiger Woche zu Allachter gegangen ist. Das heißt, sie brauchen den quasi wie neu ist. Und jetzt wird das Spotlight so ein bisschen verschoben auf Jacob Brolm. Der ist 21 Jahre, ist ein offensiver Mittelfeldspieler, der aber auch gerne mal auf den Flügeln spielt. Und der ist im Prinzip, hat ein ähnliches Skillset eigentlich wie Oliver Edvardsen. Ist sehr triplingstark, ist sehr temporeich und vor allem schafft er es auch unter Druck, die richtigen Entscheidungen schnell zu finden. Also die Entscheidungsfindung ist bei ihm echt stark und kann auch wirklich schöne, öffnende Tabellen spielen. Und das ist so ein bisschen jetzt der MVP von D-Venter jetzt nach Edvardsen-Abgang. Hat in 41 Spielen auch schon acht Tore und fünf Torlagen dabei gesteuert und hat eigentlich auch einen großen Anteil, dass D-Venter auf dem siebten Platz ist. Und bei D-Venter ist es seit einigen Jahren quasi so eine Art Redaktion, dass sie gerne Spiele aus Dänemark, Norwegen, Schweden, Finnland, aus dem Dynamischen Bereich verpflichten. Und vielleicht hat Jakob Reum auch ein bisschen Glück und die große offensive Last eines Edvardsens wird ein bisschen von seinen Schultern genommen, denn sie haben schon wie ein Neues verpflichtet, der ist jetzt 20 Jahre. Das ist Oskar Sievatsen, auch Norweger wie Edvardsen. Und der wurde am Deadline der am dritten, zweiten noch verpflichtet. Und ja, insofern hat Jakob Reum vielleicht doch nicht so die große offensive Last, aber auch Jakob Reum, call ich jetzt auch mal, wird auch nicht mehr allzu lange, denke ich mal, bei Deventer spielen. Der ist auch schon bei einigen Vereinen europäisch offenbar da. Ich habe glaube ich von dem Losinteresse von Merle Bremen gehört, aber ja, ich bin gespannt, was da passiert bei Jakob Reum. Und die Ausbildungsmaschine für Spieler aus den armen Raum, Deventer.
Dementsprechend würde ja dann auch Bremen sehr gut zu Werder passen. Denen sind Dänen ja auch durchaus ein Begriff und erfolgreich. Und jeder, der sich gefragt hat, Deventer, wer war das nochmal? Das waren die Go-Ahead-Eagles. Ich möchte, dass sie nur noch so genannt werden und auch mit dieser Begeisterung. Dann könnt ihr es zuordnen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Haben wir ja neulich drüber gesprochen in der Ligatur. Dann blicken wir nochmal ganz kurz nach Italien, Christian.
Machen wir kurz zwei Worte von mir auch noch zu Warr und Schiedsrichter. Weil Italien geht es auch gerade drunter und drüber. Letzten zwei Spieltage, große Warr-Diskussionen. Da ist das Riesenthema, aber das ist eine eigene Sendung, ist mir klar. Ich glaube, man müsste mal anfragen, anfangen drüber zu reden, über das Warr-Protokoll. Also wann reingehen, wann nicht reingehen. Inter hat gerade ein Tor geschossen nach einer Ecke, die niemals eine Ecke war, weil der Ball schon im Aus war und Tomori ist gerade mit gelber Rot vom Platz geflogen, weil er in den Zweikampf ging, wo abseits davor war. Er geht in den Zweikampf, sieht die zweite gelbe, aber es war ein Abseits. Also das ist ein Riesenthema in Italien. Also es schließt sich da an sehr, sehr schwierige Zeiten. Aber mein letztes Thema wäre, ich hätte, MVP hätte ich Colombo nie mitbringen können. Der hat einfach mal geschmeidigend in den ersten drei Spielen für Juba fünf Tore gemacht. Also der hat sich sehr schnell sehr wohl gefühlt. Und es wird dazu führen, dass Vlaović im Sommer Juwe verlässt. Das können wir dann in Ruhe nochmal quatschen. Also Vlaović sitzt nur noch auf der Bank und kommt rein. Und Juwe wird jetzt alles tun, dass Moa nie dann über den Sommer hinaus dann auch bleiben wird. Aber meine letzte Geschichte ist leider nicht nur schöne, aber passt halt rein und dürfen wir dann halt auch nicht untergehen lassen. Mois Ken spielt eine herausragende Saison, hat unter der Woche gegen, das war dieses emotional aufgeladene Nachholspiel gegen Inter, das ja damals abgebrochen wurde, weil Eduardo Bove auf dem Feld zusammengebrochen ist. Da waren noch 70 Minuten offen, es stand eben 0-0. Und das hat die Fiorentina zu Hause 3 zu 0 gegen Inter gewonnen. Doppelpackt von Ken. Das war wirklich ein unfassbar emotionales Spiel. Drei Tage später kam es schon zum Rückspiel in San Siro. Das hat dann Inter gewonnen, aber leider ist es keine sportliche Geschichte, denn nach diesem Spiel ist Mois Ken auf sozialen Netzwerken massiv rassistisch beleidigt worden und er hat das Ganze öffentlich gemacht. Er hat jeden einzelnen rassistischen Beleidigungen sozusagen gescreenshotted, hat die veröffentlicht und hat zusammen mit dem Club, mit der Fiorentina, die haben jeden dieser einzelnen Beleidigungen angezeigt. Und das, glaube ich, ist das Entscheidende. Sein Kommentar war, war schlimm, dass es das im Jahr 2025 noch gibt. Ich glaube, wir haben öfter hier schon gesprochen. Es tut weh, jedes Mal nochmal darüber sprechen zu müssen, aber so ist es anscheinend. Ich wollte die Geschichte jetzt mitbringen, dass ich es stark von ihm fand und stark von der Fiorentina, dass sie eben nicht nur symbolisch agiert haben, sondern wirklich hier jeden einzelnen angezeigt haben. Und jetzt geht es halt einfach drum. Ich meine, das ist eine gesellschaftliche Diskussion. Die hat ja nicht nur mit dem Fußball zu tun. Das betrifft ja andere Menschen, die in der Öffentlichkeit stehen. Leider auch. Jetzt geht halt zumindest, finde ich, der Finger auf die Autoritäten. Jetzt müsste man dann halt irgendwann auch mal Wege finden, um Menschen, die sowas von sich geben, dann halt auch ordentlich zu, juristisch zu verfolgen. Und ja, das juristische Ding, sie spüren zu lassen. Deswegen Respekt an Ken, weil ich finde, man kann da keinem vorschreiben, wie man mit sowas umgeht. Auch wenn jemand anders das anders lösen möchte, nicht in die Öffentlichkeit geht, glaube ich, muss man da auch höchsten Respekt haben. Aber Ken hat es so gemacht, ist ja schon vielleicht, erinnere ich noch ein paar in sehr jungen Jahren bei Juve, ich glaube damals war er 17, ist er auch schon mal in Kaljarit bei einem Auswärtsspiel von den Rängen rassistisch beleidigt worden. Da ist er auch Richtung Kurve hin, hat sozusagen die Auseinandersetzung gesucht. Also Ken ist da einer, der das, wie soll man sagen, auch öffentlich transportiert. Und ja, die Hoffnung ist, dass da sich was tut. Aber wir wissen leider alle, glaube ich, dass es solche Geschichten hat schon oft gegeben hat. Ich habe logisch auch kein Rezept, aber ich wollte es hervorheben, dass stark wie die Fiorentine und Ken damit umgegangen sind.
Aber wirklich. Und das bringt uns zum Ende dieser Sendung. Ich mach's ganz schnell. Ich danke euch vielen sehr, sehr herzlich. Ich danke auch denjenigen, die diese Sendung hier ermöglicht haben. Unter anderem Robin, JJ1860, RobertS04, Elch, BigJu und Dodge. rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Da erfahrt ihr, wie man uns unterstützen kann. Alles, was wir hier machen, ist Paywall, werbe- und sponsorenfrei von euch finanziert. rasenfunk.de und dann auf den Unterstützen-Button klicken und auch sehr gerne unsere anderen Formate abonnieren. Wir sprechen über die Bundesliga der Männer, der Frauen. Wir sprechen über Nationalteams und alle Länderspiele der deutschen Teams. Und es gibt auch neue Tribüngespräche zu dem Polizeikostenurteil. Macht's gut, bis bald, ciao!
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank!